fans will no doubt remember this iconic
scene both from the movies and from the
books when Harry and Hermione travel
back in time to save Buckbeak and Sirius
Black in the series this is where Harry
casts a full corporeal Patronus from
across the lake which of course takes
the form of the Stag now it just so
happens you'll come across this very
same Lake in Hogwarts Legacy inside the
Forbidden Forest there's actually a
mission that will take you here and when
you approach the lake there will be a
stag around the lake and your character
will even comment on the Stags that are
there
something oddly solemn about this place
such Regal creatures stacks